I love Game of Thrones I love that I
love getting lost in the mythology then
love stories the back stabbings
the battles did I mention the back
stabbings but one thing I've always been
interested in is the show's black
characters who are few and far between
Game of Thrones largely takes place in
the continents of Westeros and Essos
most of the characters are from Westeros
which is loosely based on medieval
Europe so it makes sense that these
characters are white however Westeros
and Essos are only a part of a huge
world and characters make references to
foreign regions all the time this is
especially true for the show's black
characters as virtually all of them seem
to be from the same place I come from
the summer is Isles Summer Isles so my
eye so where are the Summer Isles
they're not on HBO's official map for
the show but fans of the book series can
tell you that the islands are south of
Westeros according to the books the
summer Islanders are strong handsome
people their skin color is described as
nut-brown teak evany and jet-black their
eyes and hair are black and they're said
to highly respect their elders okay yeah
these people are black but who are they
on the show grey worm the leader of the
unsullied soldiers says he was taken
from the Summer Isles as a baby czar oh
the dude who was thirsty for Daenerys in
season two says he grew up in the Summer
Isles before moving to Qarth here I am a
savage from the Summer Isles
Salladhor saan the pirate and mercenary
who's friends with Davos Seaworth also
says he's from the Summer Isles it's
important to note that in the books none
of these characters are from the Summer
Isles HBO decided to change their race
and their background stories for the
show now let's talk about the islands
themselves the Summer Isles are said to
comprise over 50 islands but the vast
majority of its citizens live in just
three of them Jolla Milano and
burro each of these three islands is
ruled by a prince or princess and there
is little to no warfare between them
that's because the summer Islanders are
very peaceful people in fact they've
never made any attempts to conquer
foreign lands maybe the rest of Game of
Thrones characters could learn something
from them thousands of years before the
events of Game of Thrones
summer Islanders are said to have gone
through an age of exploration they first
traveled east to the island of naath
which seems to be the second of two
sources of black people in the known
world this is where Masson day Daenerys
is loyal confidant was born the people
of naath are said to have dark skin and
golden eyes apparently they're even more
peaceful than the summer Islanders due
to their belief in extreme pacifism
sadly their pacifism is the reason
slavers find the people of naath to be
good slaves this could explain why a lot
of the slaves on the TV show appear to
be darker skinned clearly there's a lot
of history to be explored in the Summer
Isles and not HBO seems to be gearing up
to do just that as it's Game of Thrones
spin-off show is casting a lot of black
actors and actresses could this mean
that the show will at least partially
take place in the Summer Isles
I pray by the old gods and the new
[Music]